Toyota unveiled the new generation of
its hybrid Aris in January of this year
now the compact is being joined by a new
station wagon the hours touring sports
we tested the hybrid version of the ours
with the mid-range equipment features
known as life fog lights a height
adjustable passenger seat and the
multimedia sound system Toyota Touch are
just some of the standard features with
that wealth of extras Toyota hopes to
convince customers who are still
skeptical about the hybrid ours
test-drive Amata's kirat says that
especially in Europe there's still some
slight growth in the market for compact
cars and station wagons so it makes
sense that Toyota is trying to fill that
niche with the are restoring sports
hoping to steal some customers away from
the competition
even the know indies Anisha of noch
einmal Donovan Park contending that the
velvet actors Nabu the station wagon
aims to be lighter and more dynamic than
its rivals the hybrid powertrain has
three modes to increase fuel efficiency
modulus montes shows us the three
buttons on the dashboard electric
vehicle or evey mode eco and power mode
in evey mode the car can drive up to 2
kilometers on the batteries alone at a
speed of around 50 kilometers an hour
that's perfect for a short shot around
the city but when the gas-powered engine
kicks in consumption turns out to be
higher than the official data with these
the mantises manufacturer's consumption
figures are rarely accurate toyota says
the hours touring sports uses 3.7 liters
as a hybrid the reality is closer to
five five and a half but that's still
good for a gasoline engine Ben Cena
ya know kinds a go to hit the price of
the new hours is also compelling the
hybrid station wagon we tested cost
twenty four thousand four hundred euros
wait the chassis space utilization and
the powertrain all were central
considerations in designing the hours
Turing sports
engineers and designers worked in close
collaboration the fruit of their labors
was built in Toyotas burn Aston plant in
England is not to montez's Europe is a
big market for station wagons so it's
not surprising the Toyota developed the
hours Turing sports in Europe and built
it in Britain the blue backing on the
Toyota logo symbolises the cars hybrid
status
and the large red cable shows how that
hybrid technology is integrated the
design of the headlights and fog lights
is new
and the large taillights dominate the
car's rear
back to the test drive Toyota engineers
have installed a CVT or continuously
variable transmission montes doesn't
particularly like the CVT transmission
he says when you hit the accelerator the
engine revs higher but there's no
relative change in speed but he admits
it could just take some getting used to
- the hood energy storage usually takes
up lots of room in a hybrid and what
about our test vehicle
let's skip the Myotis Markos Bergman
says there are no space reductions which
is important in the station wagon they
need room and flexibility and that goes
for hybrids as well there can't be any
compromises so the battery is placed out
of the way behind the rear seats without
the rear seats folded down there's
enough storage space to fit two large
suitcases in the back the cockpit is
well-organized and attractive in black
and silver
but it's one thing to look good how does
it feel
until Yangtze Mata says the designers
really went to a lot of trouble with the
interior everything fits together and
the materials feel great the dashboard
even comes with leather trimming in this
ours touring sports this is a good
overview and everything is easy to reach
newer McNutt but he says the Japanese
carmaker doesn't do buttons well on the
steering wheel they're too big and
clunky in CLE Celentano
whoops August item could Toyota's are as
hybrid touring sports it's a long name
for a car but the hybrid could make an
impact with its fuel economy and low
starting price